the military has taken control of
myanmar once known as burma in an
apparent overnight coup
civilian leaders of the southeast asian
country have been detained including
nobel peace prize recipient onsong su
chi
remy inocencio is with us from beijing
raymie good morning to you
doesn't sound good in myanmar what's
going on this morning good
good morning no not at all it very much
is a country either suspended or frozen
for example international flights in and
out have been canceled
banks have been shut and cbs news has
been trying our hardest to try to
contact people
in the country for interviews that has
also been very spotty i did manage to
contact an old friend of mine about 12
hours ago he's in yangon the former
capital
and he told me that there has been panic
buying at markets
and also people rushing to banks to try
to get their money out
[Applause]
predawn headlights of military vehicles
lit up the road to myanmar's capital
napiedau
now detained top civilian leader aung
san tsuchi
president obenment and their lieutenants
as people rushed to stock up on supplies
the military clamped down on
communication since the morning
the internet in the phone line the
mobile phone lines are cut off
so a lot of people are confused this
interview with a local filmmaker
freezing up and dying the military
alleges election
fraud in november's parliamentary polls
myanmar's election commission
has rejected that aung san tsuchi's
governing party won
in an even bigger landslide than before
in 2015.
the daughter of assassinated general
aung san the now 75 year old democracy
icon spent
15 years under house arrest peacefully
protesting against the junta
in 1991 she won her nobel prize in 2015
she rose to be the nation's top civilian
leader
tying her reputation to the military
leaders who locked her up
barack obama became the first u.s
president to travel to myanmar
but critics say she failed to address
the potential genocide of the muslim
minority rohingya
in 2017 hundreds of homes were burned
the u.n
called it ethnic cleansing and nearly
one million have fled to neighboring
bangladesh
aung san tsuchi fell out of favor with
the international community
but she still adored at home
aung san tsuchi has now called on the
burmese people to get out and protest
to push back against a return to
authoritarianism and
dictatorship and as you can imagine
around the world countries have been
condemning what's happening in myanmar
for example
the united nations uh saying that it is
a step back for democratic reform
and the white house also weighing in
threatening retaliation
gail more to come on that story for sure
thank you raymie